[Music]
oh you're the tough guy
[Applause]
[Music]
huh so unsophisticated X5 of course you
doing your own stunts now real cute real
cute you quit with the magic and fight
fair oh
it's not a fair
fight
I didn't do anything wrong yeah but
why'd you run a little over the top
don't you think all the Shadow
play I thought it was spot
[Music]
on
OB
hello we have a little bit of a
situation we wanted to run by you
mobious wow great to see you
[Applause]
again that that's what's been happen
happening wow time slipping wait time
you know that yeah you've seen that yeah
can you fix that no it's impossible to
time slip in the TVA I know but we just
saw it
happen
[Music]
yeah I've been pulled through
time between the past and the present
hello if what I saw is
true there's nothing to sound between
this world and after the
destruction only one way to find
out little good oldfashioned leg work
listen we have different styles you're a
man of action which is
fine I take a more slow deliberate
cerebral
approach it's really
[Music]
goodbye it's up to
us to save this place is this cracked
you
whatever we
do we're playing
God we are
Gods but how do you
choose who
lives and who
dies make the hard
Choice it's him you better run
war is on its
way come on you're the god of
Mischief always have been always will
[Applause]
be little over the top don't you think I
thought it was spot
[Music]
on